hi boots I miss you I want to spend time
with you every day you spend with sleepy
I miss you I miss hanging out with you
not the good old days I miss being your
friend
[Music]
let's do some Doge Doge heh what is that
ager Yoga for dogs
[Music]
oh let's do a couple chapters just like
the good old days
what are your safe votes let's do it no
there's no way we could ever do this
Maya
I'll go with you I love yoga
how do yoga with you I love yoga I do a
good marching all the time chapter one
up and down the mountain do you want to
try that Maya you want to do that one
you want to go up and down the man okay
we start with the Mountain Pose then we
stand forward and bend the utanasana in
the Tadasana and then we go to the hood
Connor salmon and then the uttanasana
and then the Tadasana oh she loves it
look at her she's so happy I [ __ ]
hate you
the book says it's okay so this is not
terrorizing your dog the book says it's
okay so don't worry about it
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
that's a what is this dog what really
drug their dog okay so in this one you
basically need your dog in the gym just
really really hard
Mortal Kombat finisher I guess your
train oh my god it's my turn to prove
myself for Pelt
oh my god Oh [ __ ] love yoga I [ __ ]
love it a [ __ ] relief for the shipment
vote finally I've never heard him do
that noise before
[Music]
Oh fatality good thing I don't have any
balls
bring your height through this front
torso it's nine I don't care okay
basically you just rub your dog's belly
I love Todd yoga you like admire am i
doing it right
we're doing the Alan Arthur Maya yes the
Alan Asha I think she likes it I think
she likes the other half set how was
this good for your dog staying for
[ __ ] sake Duke the again
perfect was it cool was it cool and you
want to do this one anger that oh Tita
trikonasana so you start off like this
then you do the booty fat chick una
receta
this one is called trusting me hey
called dog security I don't trust in him
oh that's good you trust me
oh I feel large was being built here
again how do you feel relaxed
trust me president
good dog we built some trust eat it's
working I never seen him discover what
the [ __ ] is happening now can we kill
sleepy not until you fight to the death
we had an agreement I'll get that son of
a [ __ ]
I'm ready for the advance shoot yeah you
gotta trust me
looking forward no I wanna feel good
poets I really enjoyed it
oh I feel great
oh I feel content can you see yeah the
surfer you need at least 100 percent
synchronization to pull it off
do you really think we can do it
get set
[ __ ] idiot you're so stupid
oh no no Nick you left me hanging why
why did you do it well I had kick this
friggin states [ __ ] right man this is
what you wanted all along my fingers yes
I only did yoga I tricked here so you
could be too weak to defend yourself
your fingers are mine puts their minds
and so PewDiePie was outwitted by a
[ __ ] pug
tricked into doing yoga just to tire him
out enough to eat his fingers
I've been Danny DeVito and thank you for
watching this episode don't forget to
Like and subscribe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on